tengo dos bolas verdes y tres bolas
moradas así que cuantas bolas tengo en
total bueno serán dos bolas verdes más
tres bolas moradas serán cinco bolas en
total y veis eso justo ahí hay cinco
bolas en total
podemos contarlas 1 2 3
45 ahora qué tal si hacemos algo un poco
diferente empecemos con las 5 bolas
empezaremos con las cinco bolas puedes
contar las otra vez 1 2 3 4 5 y ahora
que tenemos 2 restemos dos de estas
bolas quitemos 1 - 2
y ahora con que nos quedamos nos
quedamos con 123 bolas
nos quedamos con 3 bolas y de seguro ya
ha visto un patrón aquí 2 + 3 es igual a
5 pero si empiezas con 5 listados te
quedarás con 3 mira cómo está esto
acomodado y mira cómo está esto ha
acomodado 2 + 3 es igual a 55 menos dos
es 352 es 3 y funciona hacia el otro
lado si empiezo con 5 si empiezo con
cinco y ya quite 3 sí resto 123 con que
me quedo me quedo con 12 me quedo con
dos así que dos más 13 532 es 5 veces
esto de aquí esta es otra manera de
decir que 52 éste es o qué 5 - 3 es 2 de
esto por un momento este es un patrón
muy importante o una idea muy importante
al entender las matemáticas si sumas dos
números si sumas un 2 y un 3
tienes 2 números y obtienes otro número
si tomas ese número y le restas uno de
estos dos obtendrás el otro número